[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
september is back again the month where
the games industry starts cranking back
into motion this is the series in which
we outline the best games each month has
to offer from the full price behemoths
to the reduced and totally free-to-play
games so here's eight i think are worth
your time cue the music
arguably the biggest game of the month
is death loop an xbox owned game which
is only available on playstation and pc
it's a strange world we live in death
loop is described as a murder puzzle in
which we play an assassin trapped in a
time loop
set in first person we repeat the same
day over and over and over again the
twist is to end the loop you must take
out eight targets in a single day should
we die it all starts again you're in a
death loop my friend along the way
you'll upgrade your character's
abilities including a way to lift twice
in a single loop bending reality to suit
your playstyle whether that's all out
attack or teleporting to unseen
locations and dealing damage from the
shadows oh and there's also another
assassin here just to kill you and
they're better than you so you're gonna
die a lot death loop hits ps5 and pc on
september 14th and once the timed
exclusivity deal runs out xbox will have
this too
[Music]
next kinah bridge of spirits are you
getting deja vu that's because kina was
scheduled to release last month but
moments after i made this video last
month it was delayed until september
21st kina is a spirit guide helping
people trapped between the living world
and the dead find their way to the
afterlife essentially kina is heavily
inspired by legend of zelda which shines
through constantly i'd previously
described it as breath of the wild meets
pikmin mainly because of these cute rock
creatures who are here to help keena
along the way there'll be puzzles to
figure out there'll be exploration to
lose yourself in and a fighting system
which evolves throughout the game and it
just looks gorgeous too hopefully it
does release this time and if it does it
will be on september 21st on ps4 ps5 and
pc here's an interesting one fist forged
in shadow torch okay not the greatest
name ever but this could be a hidden gem
at a hugely reduced price over here in
the uk it's just 25 quid fist has us
playing a rabbit with a mechanical arm
attached to his back
essentially fist is a side scroller with
platforming elements and a bunch of hack
and slash fighting mechanics to get used
to with combos to master too and i even
saw some bullet hell sections we don't
know much about fist but we do know it
hits ps5 and ps4 on september 7th which
so happens to be ps plus day hmm i
wonder if this could be one of the three
games it's unlikely as the pre-orders
are available now but i wouldn't be
surprised if i'm honest and if it isn't
this is a super cheap old-school side
scroller which looks like crazy fun to
play so count me in
okay i get why most of you are here you
want a free game well here it is e
football and to clarify i mean football
and not the version where you pick up
the ball and run with it e football has
been through some changes and as of
september it will be free to play
completely on all platforms if it looks
familiar it's because the name
e-football has changed many times some
of you will know this as pez others as
pro-evo some will know this as winning
eleven it's had an identity crisis for
years now while konami has put
everything under one roof e-football is
what we're all calling it from now on
and they hope to follow in the steps of
battle royale games introducing a
free-to-play option with extras to
purchase it's still unclear if that
means there will be pay-to-win mechanics
or mystery loot boxes like in fifa so i
guess we wait and see a campaign mode is
in the works but the key to success is
flawless online play the exact date of
release is being revealed very soon in
fact it may be the same day i'm saying
this and if it is revealed i'll be sure
to update that in the info below
speaking of free games a quick note that
call of duty vanguard open beta is here
for us all on september the 18th running
over that weekend it's the perfect
opportunity to see if you want to play
more call of duty this year or you're
gonna switch to battlefield lucky i'm
battlefield okay if you're on
playstation then there is a gift for you
with this every ps4 and ps5 player will
have access to the alpha version running
from august 27th to 29th so if it's
already september this has passed but if
it's still august when you're watching
this and you're on playstation more free
stuff okay back to full price games
[Music]
did you ever play the award-winning life
is strange well six years later they are
still making those games this time its
life is strange true colours we watch
the journey of alex chen who is
desperately trying to hide her psychic
abilities which includes the power to
absorb emotions from others that she
meets
this game deals with death and coping
mechanisms so be prepared to cry your
eyes out after playing it don't worry if
you haven't played the previous games
this is a new story knowing the last six
years of content is not vital although
it would help life is strange true
colours hits you in the fields on
september the 10th on every single
platform you can imagine except the
samsung smart fridge rip
[Music]
diablo 2 resurrected comes back from the
dead this year a remaster of a hugely
successful action role-playing game made
21 years ago taking charge of a
selection of heroes and fighting through
three zones of hordes before descending
into hell to fight diablo himself of
course there's more to it than that the
rpg elements and item management is the
core hook and an interesting gothic
horror story accompanies you throughout
for a nostalgia hit of the good old days
diablo 2 resurrected is perfect but
selling this game to new players will be
the biggest obstacle they face
if you want to tunnel down to hell for a
firefight with fear look out for diablo
2 resurrected on september 23rd on
playstation xbox pc and even the switch
has a version okay a few notable
mentions the annual basketball of thon
nba 2k slams down this month on
september the 10th wrc 10 drives in your
face on september the 2nd and if you're
waiting for the new rainbow six game
this month it's been delayed to january
2022 oh
[Music]
well oh here's a game series i think is
worth your time lost judgment the yakuza
game series have been around longer than
most of us yet even with a huge fan base
most people still don't know about it in
2018 a spin-off to the series sprang up
which told the story through the eyes of
a detective investigating murder cases
and other things youtube won't let me
say it's far more hard hitting than the
yakuza franchise but it still retains
the sense of wonderment searching
through japanese locations and the
free-flowing combat is so addicting and
now we have the sequel lost judgement
continuing the yakuza side story
allowing us to stalk more shady
underworld figures lost judgment arrives
on the 24th of september on ps4 and ps5
and the xbox series
[Music]
finally they've done it again one month
after the director's cut of ghost of
tsushima we have another director's cut
this time death stranding death
stranding was the game that lets you
urinate on liquid tar monsters and walk
across the usa with bionic legs in every
way you can imagine it it was weird and
i loved it set after most of the world
had died out death stranding asks us to
reconnect america and find a way to
fight back against the bt creatures
plaguing the world and now the
director's cut is here to take the base
game up to ps5 with a bunch of new
updates including a bodybot you no
longer need to do this all alone look at
him so there we have it eight new games
coming in september 21. any catch you
fancy i'm going to try e football fist
and i really hope keena bridge of
spirits releases this month if you're
still here please write the name of the
first console you ever owned in your
entire life i will try and find you and
give you some feedback i'm adam you're
awesome i'll see you next time
[Music]